ciao a tutti vi ricordate quando a
quattro anni le maestre sono fare quei
lavoretti per la mamma e poi gli
regalava the pensando di essere il nuovo
leonardo da vinci con in mano il
progetto di un pacchetto di patatine
dimagranti
ecco ricordate la reazione di vostra
madre che tieni mamma guarda cosa ho
fatto per te somma che bello guarda me
mettiamolo qua dentro questo mobile così
lo vedo un po ma non perché non ci
facciamo un poster ecco qua in questo
modo in fumo lo farà vedere anche agli
angeli bene calcola dico una cosa simile
ma è successo a 28 anni suonati quando
ho detto a mia madre che avrei preso
parte alla serie tv o ma hanno preso per
la serie minima veramente maggio me la
immagino
ma che bella notizia che mi ha dato teso
armati che si tratta
è la storia ad un ragazzo che partecipa
mentale per realizzare il suo sogno a
sentì un poco questo caso va in
bicicletta
non credo ma ma ma non risolve qualche
crimine lancio nel felice
no ma no
ma nel menu ma che nome del cibo
vabbè sentiva di miglio del todis così
dal momento che mia mamma ha reagito
alla notizia con lo stesso entusiasmo di
chi va a curarsi le emorroidi ho deciso
di rivolgermi ad altre persone quindi
farmi capire se sono storia d'amore mesi
ap
cerchiamo da anch'io ti amo joy devi
crescere da sun ora mutati anche io ti
amo ciò anzi no anch'io ti amo paesi il
como e che mi ama no a veti scopriamo
soltanto quindi fammi capire più moderno
cioè per la più di complicità coi
genitori anche sensi si cioè in primis e
cioè questo rapporto che lui a quei
genitori
mamma vuoi farmi di eroina mentre cinque
ragazzi di nazionalità diverse fanno
scempio del mio corpo ma un'idea
fantastica facciamo insieme io porto la
telecamera un addio che bene il nostro
rapporto
viva le malattie veneree spagna la
candida pazzesco però una ferita sente
quando sarò il protagonista di questa
serie nube di niente già mamma giro
si sa solo stage mondo anche se non
dovrei sì sì sì sì perchè matri facciamo
sia sincero
tu non sei niente fuori [ __ ] scusate
ho sbagliato stanza murarie
no non è proprio così tutto quindi la
massima anche un personaggio principale
no i muri manco dei mama con nano
all'una nulla vedrò mai
quindi ragazzi siccome parenti amici
chiaramente non mi supportano ora
chiedere aiuto a voi la serie si
chiamerà baciato dal sole e verrà
trasmessa dal falso raiuno non risolverò
crimini in vicino il miglior liceale che
se trent'anni non ucciderà il suo
protagonista in un'orgia incestuosa di
nani in pratica tutti quelli questo
video estremamente fatto per promenado
serie
esatto ho fatto una serie per la rai sto
dicendo alla gente di vederla perché mi
farebbe molto piacere cantasse bella
sorella concedetemelo i miei comunque
alla fine la vedranno tra il mio
fratello
che una retro mancaza di nani